nothing can travel faster than light but
what if we switch the rules a little
imagine a world where the speed of light
was slower but the speed that sound
travels added in turn the sound in that
hypothetical world would be accelerated
until it reached the speed of light how
would the sound sound and the light look
and why would that universe be doomed
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the speed of light and sound
switched light travels at a constant
speed of 300,000 kilometers per second
if you personally were able to travel at
that kind of speed you could zip around
the earth's equator seven and a half
times in just one second if sound could
travel that fast well we'll get to that
part in a moment first let me explain
something there's one big difference
between the speed of light and the speed
of sound light speed is a universal
constant it's always the same for every
observer for sound it's different the
speed of sound depends on the density of
the medium it travels through what we
usually refer to as the speed of sound
is the speed of sound waves passing
through dry air at 20 degrees Celsius
that speed is 343 m/s and that's almost
a million times slower than the speed of
light if light traveled that slow how
different when our universe have turned
out to be
since light speed is a universal speed
limit changing it would completely
change how the universe works with the
new speed limit of 343 m/s everything
would be so you'd find that moving at
0.2 km/h would only be possible with a
rocket or at least a nuclear powered car
driving it would be a challenge as you
wouldn't be able to see far ahead but
you would experience a cool Doppler
effect around you things in front of
your car would seem blue in your
rear-view mirror everything would look
red in that world it would take hours to
send a message to someone on the other
side of the planet you know what would
be even more annoying talking to someone
who's further than a hands distance away
from you the delays in visuals would
make it look as if you were video
calling someone with a bad signal only
in person we would never be able to make
it to space because to do that we need
to escape from the gravitational
influence of Earth that requires the
speed greater than the speed of light in
our hypothetical world we'd never reach
it to begin with there would be no moon
landing no solar system exploration not
even the International Space Station on
a more disturbing note the chemical
reactions in your body would slow down
mmm that can't be good
essential functions like your metabolism
depend on those reactions I can't tell
you exactly how this would end but it
sure wouldn't take long all that and we
haven't even got to the speed of sound
yet for the sake of your survival let's
say that your body adjusted to the slow
motion inside it now sound enters the
game it's faster than light now so you
would hear everything before you got to
see it because sound relies on the
environment in order for this to happen
air would have to turn incredibly dense
we're talking as dense as neutron stars
not a single living organism would
survive under such strong pressure not
to mention that all this breaks the
rules of physics nothing can exceed the
universal speed limit and if sound did
travel faster that's not good news for
anyone the universe would collapse upon
itself long before we got to experience
cool Doppler effect next time try
increasing the speed of light instead of
decreasing it that's a story for another
what F
[Music]